en ce moment ben on ne sait absolument
pas où on va quels sont exactement les
tenants et les aboutissants de cette
réforme euh on a l'impression d'un flou
généralisé et donc je vais proposer au
prochain conseil
municipal
de appliquer cette réforme en 2014 il
faut qu'on arrive avec les partenaires à
bien réfléchir de manière à ce que cette
transformation encore une fois soit dans
l'intérêt de l'enfant soit positive et
apporte réellement un bien-être en terme
de de rythme et nous le ferons dans les
mois qui viennent avec un objectif la
rentrée 2014 la semaine des 4 jours et
demi ne s'appliquera certainement pas
pour la rentrée scolaire 2013 si
certains maires de Saint-Quentin en
Yveline ont décidé d'appliquer ce
nouveau rythme en 2014 d'autres sont
encore indécis ils attendent davantage
de précision de la part du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale c'est le cas des
communes d'élencour de la verrière de
trappe de Montin le Bretonneux et de
maniléa
il faut prendre le temps d'étudier
toutes ces possibilités pour la mettre
en place au mieux dans le meilleur
confort possible pour les enfants et
bien sûr aussi pour les enseignants et
tous les services concernés la commune
ne s'est pas encore positionné
officiellement activité extrascolaire
mode de garde transport scolaire
beaucoup de paramètres sont à prendre en
compte sans parler de l'impact sur le
budget des mairies et du jour retenu
pour cette demi journé en plus mercredi
ou samedi à l'heure actuelle trop de
questions demeurent sans
réponse